I feel like I'm just like even finally
coming into my own
I'm fed up and fed up with the pain and
we need to be talking about it more and
the realities of what the impacts are on
LGBTQ people's life and we have when we
have so little representation it's
upsetting
[Music]
walkabout together with me Josh Smith
and today we're joined by the geniuses
behind Netflix is a new smash hit and
Birla Academy kelan like if I was
growing up today
and I had you as a role model I would
feel so grateful your character is like
perceived as an other because she
doesn't have these skills that you ever
want to have and she's kind of
ostracized by her family in some way
when you were going to play this
character watch to draw on from your own
experience I was immediately intrigued
with vanya because I just related I
related to the feeling of folding in on
yourself struggling with depression
anxiety barely feeling like you can take
any space up in the room and and what it
sort of took to get out of that you know
in my experience and a lot of that came
from you know certain things I don't
want to talk about and then also things
like you know yeah growing up gay in a
place that was not a you know hellofax
Nova Scotia then was not that was not a
queer positive space and and then my
experiences as an actor and then in the
film industry particularly in my early
mid-20s which I just dealt with like
rampant homophobia and misogyny and in
people being shitty so I had my stuff to
deal with and I related to Vanya and her
pain and I wanted to yeah
explore that how do you feel more
empowered than that to stand up and let
your voice be heard I feel like I'm just
like even finally coming into my own
to be honest like in a real major way
and I think alongside of what's
happening in our world that's been
happening in our world for a long time
forever um and particularly after
traveling around the world and making
the show called vacation that I made
it's life or death you know these issues
that we are talking about our life and
death and a lot of the issues we're
talking about seem to be debates in the
media and they're not you know and so I
think at this point it's it's it's just
at a point where I am fed up
and fed up with the pain and we need to
be talking about it more and the
realities of what the impacts are on
people's life and on LGBTQ people's life
and we have when we have so little
representation whether it's in a film or
television or in like news media we're
not hearing about the things we
shouldn't be hearing about the story is
what's going on in Chechnya etc it's
just like it's upsetting so when you
come to a correcting a show which is so
amazing and so mean
layered characters they discuss
different types of masculinity happiness
all those kind of things it's not the
message that you have in the back of
your head that you want to bring out
different is good different is not bad
and I think that's the message of the
show I mean there's many messages but I
think we we have to embrace difference
and not look at it as something bad just
a horrible lie tonight the soundtrack of
mist is popping yes it is is popping
what song would you guys want to perform
their musical spit off this I mean I
love dancing in the moonlight I thought
that's one of my favorites what about
you the end of episode 7 there's an
awesome sequence with Radiohead Dustin
Shaw survivor we get a series two will
be on the way do you love that song yeah
yeah we do - yeah there's some summer
lives together
[Music]